well I'm disappointed
um that it's come to this and I know
many parents will be really worried
about upcoming strikes what I want to
see is everybody getting around the
table and resolving these issues they
can be resolved at the sooner they're
resolved the better are the teachers
right to continue to strike them and
reject this offer I'm disappointed that
we're still in this situation are you
disappointed with the government or the
teachers I think both sides need to get
around the table what we've seen in
these disputes have been many disputes
over the last six months or so it needs
the government and the Trade union to
get around the table to compromise and
to agree a settlement so that we can
have our schools open and other public
services are working properly
okay so kirst armor they're saying that
he is disappointed that those
negotiations broke down
um the union did not agree to the latest
offer um circus summer in Hartlepool
he's been meeting with community members
affected by anti-social behavior and he
also spoke about child exploitation
let's have listened to that
child sexual exploitation is a problem
and we should do whatever we can to Bear
down on it when I was director of public
prosecutions between
2008-2013 with my crown prosecution
service we brought these cases the first
Rochdale grooming case was one that I
gave the green light to so there's a bit
of frustration here with the government
because for a decade we've been calling
for stronger measures things like
mandatory reporting and the government's
turned a blind eye so anything can now
be done to improve the situation well
yes good but I think the question for
the government is what have you been
doing for the last 10 years is the
government right to think about
ethnicity perhaps gather data on this or
is Tracy brabin right to think when you
start talking about this it's dog
whistle politics well look ethnicity is
important and nothing should get in the
way of investigating Prosecuting child
sexual exploitation but if you look at
the overall figure that is you know a
relatively small element of it that
doesn't mean it's not to be dealt with
don't get me wrong but if we are not not
clear about the full picture then we
won't have a proper response so I want a
government that recognizes the full
response that's needed here and a
government that really has been behind
the curve now for a decade and you know
very many of the measures I was calling
for for 10 years ago the government
still hasn't done and it's not tackling
online issues so there's big gaps in
something which is 10 years too late but
look we'll work with anybody to improve
the situation here